We just saw that in computer science, you might write a function like this.
First we name the function, in this case we named our function decrease by 3.
Then we create a spot for the input, which we call x and put it in parentheses,
and then we define what the output is going to be with this return statement.
And then we write the output right here, x minus 3. But as you've probably come
to realize over the course of this class, some people who do math a lot are a
little bit lazier, like me. For one thing, in math, the name of the function is
not usually nearly as inventive as it is in computer science. We can see that a
programmer would call a function something like this, decrease by three, that
really describes what the function's doing. In math though, our names for
functions are really simple. In fact, the most common one is probably just the
letter f. What programmers and mathematicians do in common however, is that they
still use the parentheses around what's going to be the input for the function.
And of course, x does seem like a pretty great input. Now the programmer has a
return statement, that represents what the output of this function's going to
be, only around the program. But in math, we just create an equation. So if we
want to create the decrease by three equation in math instead, we just write f
of x equals x minus 3. The output is just that expression that we've often seen
written to describe the deep ended variable, showing how it depends on the
independent variable. Now the way that we read the left hand side of this
equation right here is we say f of x. Now again, just like in programming, the
parentheses here around the input do not mean multiplication. So the output of
the function, the thing that's just equal to x minus 3, is this f of x over
here. And remember we used to say that the output was y, if the input was x. So,
what we're really doing in functions is replacing the independent variable, y,
with this new way of writing it, f of x. I think you'll see over time why this
is a useful way of writing it. But it doesn't make the original way we learned
any less valid. They're just different ways of expressing pretty similar things,
assuming that this is a function. Now that you've seen how both computer science
and mathematics would represent the same function in different ways, I'd like
you to translate the first function that we talked about from Python into its
mathematical form. So this is the function that we initially called Increase By
Two. I'd like the input to be x, and the output to be x plus two. I'd also like
you to name the function f. So just like we did up here, write the mathematical
form of the function down in this red box.